warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised this is bail
worship these are all elements which we
are going to speak
of we have the pentagram there we have
of course skulls we have goats we've got
the sun wheel hopefully you've seen the
last video we did on the origins and
we're going to start seeing and being
able to identify the sun wheel we we are
going over such a dark topic because you
have to learn to identify it in our
culture today it's been hidden it's been
repackaged as so many different things
we have to be able to see
[Music]
it what's crazy is through all these
different civilizations I mean reading
in the Bible Bale pops up a lot and in
just history I mean this was a major
Mogul yeah you know false God that that
a lot of society has has battled over
the years um falling prey to worshiping
that and probably many today don't even
realize it but he's still alive and well
and pops up in our culture all the time
yeah doing what we're talking about
right now is exposing deception there's
a world of people out there in our
culture who are just consuming things
and thinking it's normal like what do
you mean this is just a group on this
this is normal right and so to talk
about this is to open people's eyes to
show them Jesus said do not be deceived
that was the first thing he said when
they said what will be the sign of your
coming and the last days and all this
don't be deceived and like how can
you how can you wake people up or how
can people not be deceived if they don't
see it for what it is if it's not
unveiled to them right yeah I think you
also have to look at the Bible as a
pattern like we have a unique
perspective in our world because we have
all this history to look at so we can
see culture after culture after culture
that's Fallen prey to this and
unfortunately many of God's people who
claim they followed God constantly
falling prey to this God yeah so it
might be in our best interest to kind of
understand well what is it about this
God what what how how does he operate
and what is how is he getting into our
society so that we don't accidentally
fall prey to this or unwarily you know
start engaging in worshiping this well
like Solomon says there's nothing new
Under the Sun that's right noint
intended right um so these things can be
recognized they're pretty easy to
recognize because of this consistency so
I'm looking forward to to hearing your
presentation and seeing you know what's
out there what is it like in today's
context of course yeah it's going to
apply very heavily to today um I'd like
to bring up the verse since we're making
it relevant here that exactly for lack
of knowledge my people perish is
paraphrased but is that Bible verse that
God is worried about us we have to know
the truth again to discern what's going
on today some of these images just so
everyone knows are graphic to a point
where we can understand the depth but
not too graphic to scar all of our minds
so I want people to
see the depth the the gross details if
you will for a second mhm so here's a
few more images we have of TR how it
might look in the times um let's go back
to like Sodom and
gomorah and then when Jesus purged the
Earth of all of its iniquity because
humans were partaking in this stuff this
is what it might have looked like and
then we need to recap because I I heard
some people I want to clarify sin did
enter the world through the Garden of
Eden right when man fell there was
someone who said are you saying that at
nimrod's time that's When sin entered
the world no I'm not it was repackaged
again so s entered the world through
Satan in the garden with Eve and then it
ensued until Sodom and gamor where all
of this was already at its peak almost
if you will and Jesus or God had to
squash It For the First Time mhm Adam
and Eve's first son became a murderer so
you know there was a lot of evil in the
first family yes you know when this came
on screen I thought I was looking at the
Grammys for a second oh yeah I mean this
is what I see to me if I if I had put on
spiritual glasses think about it Sam
Smith and the whole audience is just
painted with red light and everybody's
wearing horns and they're in cages and
their hands are lifted up and they're
half naked and it's just like this is
going on in our world today guys like
yeah it hasn't gone anywhere yeah we've
talked about that in in terms of like a
lot of the modern um music scene um I
bet you if you went back into time and
you looked at what some of these worship
ceremonies were like I guarantee you
you'd be like that looks like it's came
out of this concert like in today you
know so yeah we're still battling this
stuff today was such a counterfeit
counterfeit it actually reminds me
of uh the sanctuary think of the
sanctuary uh the lamb represents Jesus
right and every atonement that's every
year the priest would take the sins of
the people and put it on what a goat a
goat and the Goat was led into the
Wilderness and and you know stayed there
until it died and what are they what are
they worshiping right thing that's
carrying the sin right so it's such a
flip instead of worshiping Jesus the
Lamb of God who takes away the sins of
the world there's an obsession with
worshiping sin or the the S symbol of
sin good observation there's also one
thing I'm noticing about this picture
and I don't know how accurate it is but
there's a lot of nakedness and it's just
a reminder of
how Satan always wants to uncover and
expose and make us vulnerable only to
attack us When sin was first introduced
into the world Adam and Eve fell because
of their decision and they saw their
nakedness then Christ comes in and what
does he do he covers and and wants to
protect that vulnerability which is
exact opposite of what's being displayed
here it's also about uh being Shameless
you know everything about the world what
they stand for is about you know I'm I'm
un ashamed I'm I'm this way I'm I have
this lifestyle I can show all this
embrace it yeah and yeah it's all about
and and God said you know don't let your
nakedness be seen and don't dress like
the opposite gender or whatever all
these things that he said don't do the
world's like I'm going to do it and I'm
and you're not going to judge me for it
you know you guys ready to dive in let's
do it all right okay so let's
investigate the definition or meanings
behind the name of Baal so Baal means
owner Lord and husband mhm Isaiah
describes the relationship with God is
as the husband and you know so it's
interesting that they're counterfeiting
that to address one thing too because
this comes up a lot people are like when
you say Lord you're saying bail like if
you call the Lord the word Lord in the
English it it means master so if you're
calling the if you know that you serve
Yahweh and you say he's my Lord you're
not saying he's my Baal you're saying
he's my Lord and Master but the word
bail is a generic word for the word Lord
I don't know some people get hung up on
some of that stuff and it it really just
causes a yeah it's similar to the word
teacher because in the Hebrew times they
said master and if you get caught you
can call someone your master that's evil
as well but teacher is not a bad word in
itself master not nor his husband or
Lord um so he also had the symbols of
being a bull a goat a ram half human
half goat and bull whatever you want
mixed in there and um we have some
depictions there from the bathamit now
was molok and Bale one and the same
because I I always heard that was molok
I'm glad you brought that up because
we're going to visit the many names of
Bale or Satan we'll just put them all in
the same category because masquerades as
so many different gods and of course he
sets up different demons in in charge of
each different God and each different
lust and Temptation principalities if
you will he's got a hierarchy that works
that way wiccans will tell you that they
know which principality to work with if
they're trying to get you to do certain
things anyway getting back to this he is
the god of fertility the weather rain
especially Rainman is one of his names
we're going to dive into that in the
next um few minutes
wind lightning Seasons war and soldiers
what about
Prosperity yes so that is huge um it's
not listed in here I got some of these
names from um
exposing the music industry um film
which oh please go and watch that yeah
the whole thing good yeah Parts one
through 10 don't miss one I got these
other definitions here actually from a
Wiccan website and it says baam it
humanoid goat creature most notably
figures in Satanism official logo type
for the Church of Satan inverted bamit
head is a
pentagram um it is be elub in demonology
also known as Satan so as it pertains to
using the name Rainman this is something
or referring to rain it would be given
um as an individual's name you could say
I am Rainman no matter what gender you
are to try to um pay homage to Baal so
that he will bless your life with fame
money Prosperity yeah it's the same as
all these people we we've talked about
this a lot but you know Satan offered
Jesus all the kingdoms of the world he's
the God of this world he can give you
all these riches and everything but
these are all temporal things store not
your Treasures here on Earth but store
your Treasures in Heaven because you you
can't take any of it with you it's all
going to burn one day right and um so
but these people who have taken that
offer a lot of celebrities whether
they're basketball players musicians
whatever you'll see them throw those
signs up with their hands the 666 the
horns and they'll just sit there and
Flash them back to back you're like why
are they doing that I've literally seen
like LeBron or somebody he's not even
looking at the camera the camera's he's
just looking kind of up and just like
flashing he's just like what is he doing
but he's just giving Allegiance just
like we would be praying like God help
me help me do this thing you know speak
through me the more times that you can
actually pay homage through symbols
through whatever you do and say the more
it's said that you are going to be
blessed with Fame and Fortune you call
on Rain Man or rain meaning that someone
in reference to someone who offers
Abundant Blessings from above someone
who likes to Make It Rain meaning here's
how we get into symbolism here um I'm
reading from that area throwing money on
strippers or towards strippers usually
carrying a lot of cash in his hand ready
to throw someone who can give you any
woman or man you desire someone who can
make you rich or
famous the Rainman symbolism can be
shown in several ways but mainly in pop
and Hip-hop music it is shown by
throwing money or having money appear to
be coming down from
above so Rainman is um as we're
connecting the dots baffet or the devil
and they will um use the words Rainman
rain umbrella Ella and a for some reason
those are like the key terms for you
invoking Rainman I think it's also
important to know like um in the Bible
when we when we have the stories of Baal
uh
Israel you know in the in the years of
Elijah yeah they were worshiping Baal
and they were saying that the rain came
from Bale you know and stuff and so it's
it's it's interesting to see like like
that where this comes from and and what
it actually means because yeah it's
weird that we still have that problem in
our culture how sensitive should we be
cuz these you're saying key words to
invoke the rain man which is the devil
so like something like Ella someone has
a pet or a child and they want to name
and you're you're you're calling that
person that name how sensitive should we
be as a culture even eh in that song
it's such a catchy song that song gets
stuck in my head umbrella but uh when
you when you hear the same pattern of a
word or multiple words you don't know
like which comes first when she says
umbrella you you hear umbrella and she
says Ella
Ella but she's saying L but the next
time she's saying L again so now it
could be La l l l l you hear I saying La
L okay and those words La means no and L
is God so she's repeatedly saying no God
no God no God that's in the Hebrew you
got to look into that I would think that
within the song there's a lot of
repetition so when you're talking about
invoking or evoking something and and
casting spells and all these things
there is a lot of repetition that goes
into that so context does matter I I
don't know definitively if like
calling if that's a nickname someone has
or a pet don't know but the context of a
song and it's a a posture of wor worship
or a chance you know that that yeah I'm
glad you brought that up context I think
is important it is so the context of how
this is brought out if your if your
child is named Ella I don't think that
that's like you know you're evoking
Satan yes the cont kid name is Lucifer
well yeah yeah yeah don't call him Lucy
and it's a whole package because in her
music video as the chorus is being sung
the visual is her in rain and the thing
is someone watching this be like oh that
makes sense cuz the song is umbrella and
what do you use umbrellas for in rain
but putting all these elements together
oh man so intentional D that thing goes
so deep man like the the rain splashes
on her stomach specifically and they're
talking about fertility and then like
when it splashes at the screen it makes
a BFF it symbol the rain shape dud it's
there's no accidents in graphic design
I'll tell you that as a graphic designer
myself it might like whoops I
accidentally made a bam head the screen
like it just doesn't happen yeah so as
we're speaking of this now we're
actually going to watch some some clips
of how this is all put together here
what your name be
[Music]
Rainman iow up more cash and change the
forecast your boyfriend is lame I make
it rain on you Ro out
[Music]
of when when you know if you look up
like you've heard they sign their name
and blood and this contract and
everything that I I I kind of deep dived
into that one time and and it is the
Rainman that they're actually selling
their soul to that that they're that
they're signing this contract to wow we
make movies about it there was a movie
about some rock band that I don't
remember the name of that but it was
like look if they're making movies about
it everybody knows about it why why do
people talk about it you know it's like
there's got to be some truth to this I
think that there's enough evidence you
know if Satan has so many different
names no nobody's going to sign their
name in a contract with Satan I I say
nobody but there are some people but
what if his name is Sony right or Emi
you know like okay so there's like major
corporations that have different
subnames like there's Disney and then
there's uh buav Vista or whatever like
what if you're signing your name in a
contract with Sony but the one who owns
that is Satan himself
I think it's like Ministries you got all
these different Ministries which are
different facets but really they're
behind the scenes right we're all trying
to at least the the ones that are
wanting to follow the Bible are all
trying to operate underneath what God
wants you know for the church to have
right I think the devil's just
counterfeiting that he's got his
ministries and these are his ministries
yeah these are his ministers I think so
especially as that connects to John
Todd's story again he was put in charge
of the entire Capital Records company I
think under the Illuminati and the
council that he was on so that yeah I
love that clip he goes you know parents
come up to him and say how many demons
do do you have in your home how many
demons do how do I know if I have demons
in my home he goes go home and count
your records that's how many demons you
got yeah man it's a big spiritual
warfare well and I feel like it's
pertinent to bring this up because we're
just you know first looking at his name
and in the music
industry we're gonna go so much deeper
but
again this brings us to why do we want
to look into this why
because for one we care about other
Generations we care about our children
we care about where the world is going
and we've almost dealt with it with
white gloves on straight jackets and
proper language and political
correctness and everything I don't know
why but or sidestepped it all together
some of these topics because we just
don't want to touch on them I don't know
but we have to address them this is why
because it's blatant it's in your face
and when you're especially the youth the
children if they're in a home where
they're never exposed to it as well
about what's going to come at you when
Satan comes at you he comes at you
you're going to experience it how do you
deal with it you know MH that's right as
we dive deeper we have to go back to
nimrod's story oh yeah so once again I'm
going to recap God was gracious I know
it might sound kind of weird to some
people but he gave us a second chance
after Sodom and Gomorrah and the flood
that was the first
time then we started populating the
Earth through Noah his three sons ham
had a son named Kush Kush had Nimrod we
touched on that a little bit
earlier um now we're going to go back to
what happened when Nimrod died when he
died because Shem killed him Samus kind
of took over she was a
little fox behind everything everything
it seems um so he of course recapping
became known as the son God she she made
this up by the way he died and none of
this was Associated exactly with him he
was the one who started the Bale worship
and the killing of children and
everything and the statues but then she
was like oh I'm going to perpetuate the
myth that he is a son God I am the moon
goddess and then our son because I had a
son is tamuz
um so a little bit behind the story not
only did they sacrifice babies and
children and humans not only did they
have a counterfeit day of the sun
because that was what they were
worshiping it was Sunday as we get into
it they had
confessionals wow they set up priests
and these priests were said to be the
defi Divine mediators between samiramis
and the sun god interesting so only she
could know your secrets and only the
priest could be told and go back to her
and tell her everything about you oh she
just love Gossip yeah controlling
people
so you know they all had to take secret
Oaths they all had to deal with magic
they all had to do certain
rituals
and like if any of this is ringing a
bell oh yeah I'm thinking of all the
fraternities you got the initiations and
you got
yeah do the ritual and all that
yeah and she loved to be called The
Queen of Heaven or queen mother or
mother Universe mother of the world uh
Mother
Nature so that's kind of where all of it
comes from but here's where at least
from my point when we we get back to all
of the different methods that are being
used we get back to all the symbols that
have been repackaged and quite honestly
we think we're rediscovering them today
they were all kept in a library at the
island of Alexandria
why because when Shem killed Nimrod all
the Believers of Baal were scared and
they fled to the island of Alexandria H
where they practiced heavily every
method they honed their skills in every
method of the occult and then they built
the Library of
Alexandria which housed all of its
Secrets the caldian Mysteries Babylonian
secrets of the god
every book on everything was written and
stored you know you're talking about
that this woman she set up this whole
false this like counterfeit system of
worship and that there was these uh
priests that like a confessional Type
Thing 1 Timothy 2:5 says for there is
one God and one mediator between God and
Men the man Christ Jesus we as men
humankind we can come directly to God by
praying uh to Jesus you know he's the
mediator between us and and God you
don't have to go to a confessional that
whole system is false that you you pray
to a priest or call a mana and all these
things um I just wanted to clarify that
for anybody watching being like oh um
yeah there's only one mediator that's
Christ Jesus no that's a good point if
you go back and you really look talk to
wiccans or look at satanic pages and so
on they're always trying to get back to
the Mysteries discovering all the
Mysteries that were
lost when the library was like burnt
down as they say I don't know if it was
or just destroyed but they're always
trying to ReDiscover and find it it's
interesting how Freemasons even as it
gener generationally is passed down from
one to another they are given usually a
book of
secrets a book which retains their
rights and sacrifices and rituals so
this is where I think about that yeah
yeah God is is not secretive with the
information if he he says if you seek
you will find right so there's there's
not this like hidden knowledge that you
know only the select few are going to
understand God's asking you know he's
telling us if you want to know all you
have to do is seek after me and you will
know and and and so that counterfeit is
is really like the devil's way I think
of just you know making it this like
special thing over here and you know if
he gets Generations together and
families that you know buy into this
kind of a thing yeah I mean it's yeah
some of this stuff goes centuries
deep yeah bail worship was in full swing
we have the Queen of Heaven I'm
emphasizing that because in the Bible
you will find samiramis under that name
the Queen of Heaven is mentioned
specifically several times in the
Egyptian culture Nimrod became Osiris
the husband's son and frequently was
called Horus the Sun God and we
understand that we probably recognize
that from the IHS Isis Horus
Seb in Phoenicia samiramis and tamuz
were worshiped as or known as asth and
tamuz in Greece Aphrodite and Aeros in
Rome Venus and Cupid and in China mother
Shing muu and her child so each God as
we go through this as Bale worship s
Satan worship is
repackaged under you know I guess Sun
worship is included in that each God has
a consort or spouse companion that it's
given so again it's a
mother um son cult sometimes it's
referred to or just a trinity of of gods
really um father mother son over and
over and over again
yeah it's it's fascinating to me to see
all these different cultures that had a
basically a mother child situation the
child being you know some special child
that's going to save the world and all
of these
prophecies they they actually are in
every single culture yeah from Africa
China India you name it there there
there's examples in all of them but but
that prophecy came out of the Garden of
Eden and you know Satan was present when
that was told to Adam and Eve and so
he's really twisted and tinkered with
the cultures down the line and given
false versions of that rather than Jesus
being the baby that was going to save
people from their sin that's why he's
named Jesus Matthew 1121 call his name
Jesus because he'll save his people from
their sin so all these are just
counterfeits all these mother child
thingies that have nothing to do with
your morality but they quote unques the
saviors of the world um yeah Devil's
just mess seen with that that true model
I also think it's very fascinating that
that the devil doesn't just come up with
something totally different than what
God's doing right like like man if you
want your own government your own thing
why don't you just go off in the corner
of the universe and do something totally
different why do you got to counterfeit
what God's got going on because I will
be like the most high is his goal and
exactly good good good observation and I
also think that Satan was programmed in
the beginning to glorify God he's
created to talk about God to to share
the things of God so all he's done is
tweaked and perverted that but he's
still basically twisting but it's still
talking about the government of God and
he's just changed the order of things
and well we look at these celebrities
and we're like I want to be just like
them like I wanted to be Marilyn Manson
but I wanted to do it more I wanted to
be more shocking and more edgy and and
when you look at God he's as high as you
can get he's the god like he's the one
and if you want to be like him then or
if you want to be like the man then you
got to be like him but Satan just hates
his rules and laws even Satan is
admitting that God is the only true God
I will be like the most high not one of
the most high that's interesting wow
that's so true here's where we're just
going to do a recap this is most of the
world and what you're going to see their
names under on the left we have Nimrod
and Sun worship on the right here some
Miss's names that you will see um
perpetuated
and hidden as different things this is
the name of Baal as it's changed
throughout every Century every culture
in the world what's up with Y so I think
I think maybe what that is is the Jewish
Mystics they're into cabala and stuff
they supposed they worship Yahweh they
probably tell you I worship Yahweh but
it's like do you really I me they don't
mean the same God you mean so Baal being
the god that they said rides in the
clouds in the heavens his Archen enemy
was M which is like the god of death
yeah and uh it was there they have a
storyline where Bale comes down from the
Heavens to fight the god of Death Dies
is resurrected back to life and um and
ends up being the savior of the world I
mean it's pretty fascinating how like
similar they they followed this idea of
God and fighting Satan right but
flipping it around right it's like we we
continue to have um what do they call it
mythology in our culture today they're
just packages superhero movies yeah they
just put spandex on them yeah yeah and
they say they're all different because
of the different names and of course
they were they faced off with each other
and all this but it's really the same
story over and over again with just just
a little different twist y little
different children political world yeah
yep his name is Bale different spellings
M Kash Marduk why is that matter because
you'll actually find those in the Bible
if you look wow um tamuz of course is
specified in the Bible specifically as
well a few times so that's for our
viewers to know this is a bunch of names
that we want to understand is actually
masquerading as bail worship still as we
cover Bale this is the way of course
other statues that he might be
depicted with and then we have the
babies being sacrificed
um there's always that in this and
that's why all the chambers in this
middle picture here for multiple
sacrifices at one time
so anal sex between males and male
worshippers or male and female
worshippers was always Associated like
sodomites yep to worship the goddess as
it says Temple prostitution in those
ways as well some 1,450 years after
Leviticus the Apostle Paul references
Pagan Worship in Romans 1:26-27 when he
blasts the same kind of fertility
goddess Worship in first century Rome
here's where it all begins because as
you have this prostitution that's to the
goddess or or to the gods you have
transgenderism you have eminite uh
males you have females that are
transitioning as well you've got all
this stuff coming on the scene yeah so
you think this is a modern issue but
this is actually something that that has
come around exactly it's been around
forever in um Mesopotamia in nature the
ideal Pagan priest is both female and
male or androgynous um if if you want
more proof on that I'll give you a link
um the God anut we're going to touch on
her was an androgynous had androgynous
Priests of Mesopotamia same as cbel Ria
which refuse to be one gender themselves
but gender neutral wow possessing
character and physical attributes of
both um their priests would do M
mutilation in the highest order
attainable in witchcraft as well wiah
Satan worship spiritualism the occult it
is bisexual homosexual or Aphrodite or
androgynous
transgenderism transgenderism excuse me
that is
prized yeah you know it's it's
interesting looking at alist Crowley's
life and he would do these long lengthy
um occult rituals sometimes that would
take a year plus to perform them I mean
we're talking like every day they'd go
out and they'd do something and he was
out in the desert by himself with his um
Little Helper and they would usually
have this Circle that he would do this
this um particular whatever Ault cult
ceremonial thing in and to invite the
spirits in and one day he invited his
little um helper into the circle and
started performing homosexual acts on
him and it was a shortcut to the Demonic
world and he went like here I'm doing
all these rituals for a year long to get
like this result when all of a sudden I
could just do homosexual acts and cut
straight to the Chase and and I mean
that's that's that's been documented he
wrote books about this MH so that's
pretty interesting that that that this
is part of the the way to do that yes
every every
satanic uh practice or ritual is just
some perversion of something God Made
You know God made them male and female
no I'm gender neutral I'm fluid I can go
in between all these things that's not
the law that God made that's not the
order that he made and and same with sex
it was between one man one wife in a in
that marriage bed and yet now it's like
no we have orgies no we do it this
perverted way and that perverted way MH
and you know everything cutting yourself
all these things are things that were
not God's design right and you're right
as aler Crowley wrote is the more people
the more Partners the more gruesome it
got the
more Transcendence you would almost get
or honor from the gods so
it was definitely a portal if you will
that they will call it they probably
would call it that too but um which
makes you understand why they had Temple
prostitutes it was like this is how we
do our rituals through sex magic but
that also speaks to the truth of of
sexuality it it is spiritual it is a
spiritual experience and and when it is
done in the context that God intended it
to be done in a marriage and a committed
marriage um you know there's a there's a
spiritual blessing that happens there
yes for sure um interestingly enough we
start we notice the sun symbol coming in
with the Seal of Anana in the middle
there and she's standing on a lion's
back and you'll see why that's important
she has wings on her which transitioned
into having
also the owl the owl symbols and an yeah
owl feet as well and that's going to be
important because as you look for more
symbols of her you will find her with
the owl and with the lion over and over
again so because the serpent wants his
wings back oh yeah yep so that's another
image of her just a little more again
cultured for their day in Rome I bet and
um here's her with lions in the middle
it is cybel she's just known under a
different name again in the middle she
is a a lion drawn carriage I see the
Statue of Liberty up there what yep in
the middle middle for the Seal of cybel
right there um that was the seal they
actually used to put like kind of like
Caesar's seal for some reason they had
cybel seal um in India she was known as
kie um interesting that you have the
lion again but you also have the
cornicopia in her hand bringing
fertility blessings food Harvest um
again towards the right in the last one
she's depicted as a very large large
individual you get through this and the
last two pictures here that I'm going to
point out for cybal is so these are both
male priests to her and this is how they
used to dress or be um so obviously they
didn't have it seems the ability to
cover up their maless as as well as they
might have hoped such as today when
we're trying to get rid of you know
someone being completely male or female
and just become the other gender yeah
they were definitely a
mixture um and just touch on that you
can tell that this is also Lady Liberty
in a way but this is a male priest this
God that they are worshiping and
depicting like this is a god of
thresholds that means your home like
providing for you again the fertility of
the land and so on transitions they mean
that specifically for gender
fluidity I read an entire part on that
and just for this presentation to
understand that they believe she could
actually cause someone
to become male if they were female and
so on just to go back and forth wow um
she was also known for her street
Raves so that's interesting because we
don't think they have Raves and loud
music and stuff back then but they do um
this is a actual advertisement I found
online for today it's
2023 it actually talks about this idea
that people who have the queer Spirit or
this androgynous of feminite um
understanding or they want to be that
way were known to be The Clairvoyant
mediators or channels for the spirits
yeah they were given a knowledge that no
one seemed to have into the spirit world
we have been called Gatekeepers and
Bridge Builders so they were also known
as shamans and the healers in all I it
actually ties in all cultures that all
of them were known as this when you get
to African
Egyptian um Peruvian to Da and you'll
find that so interesting that it ties
back especially to our day yeah I just
think you know like you said there's
nothing new Under the Sun it's it's it's
interesting to me to really deep dive
into history and be like you know we
think we're we're so like debaucherous
and this world is just falling apart but
man this seems like the devil's been
hammering at this way back when and we
just keep circling around the same
issues yes so transition in to another
name for samiramis or the different gods
which she's known as
Ashira we know her because basically air
poles and they would have been seen as
this this the poles in the Middle with
just little rivets um ones with complete
heads and busts as you can see on the
left this man is hewing one out that is
complete doll almost if you will of a
female Shir was always represented with
wood and trees these are just proof in
other historical settings these are all
from all different cultures again
Babylonian Samaran Canaanite Egyptian
and so on depictions of trees is that
what they had the Groves yes a lot of
their things were in groves yes and then
you would just Hue Hue out a tree into a
doll you know into a female most of the
time and just start worshiping and doing
your sexual stuff so this picture in the
middle at the top that's what it is
naturally and then they Hue that into
their sculptures so just as though we're
going to touch on this as well in the
next couple slides but just as an
obelisk yeah it looks more phic phic
this is kind of like a pull
for all genders if you will to have
orgies at and that's not a tree that's
actually what they left it looking like
so sometimes it's just a mound that
looks rounded or squared or triang
triangular carve those shapes in there
they do or it's an higher figure of a
female okay um but the tree itself
actually represents the same God so this
is actually where we get the Christmas
tree from this is what you're doing is
you're putting up a pole to Aira stard a
asth in your home because there's
significance to that date December 25th
yes it's tamu's birthday yeah and um if
you're honoring his mother samiramis or
asth or cybel or whoever you are going
to
be it's related to always having a poll
of some sort that is sexual that
represents the fertility rights you're
going to be carrying out offer gifts to
that's what I was going to ask is there
a direct connection where when they
gathered at this poll they would bring
gifts they would worship all that so
here's another thing if you want to know
all of that we're going to be covering
that in the next holiday presentation so
stay tuned I don't know if you're going
to mentioned this or if there's any sort
of connection but I just kind of had
this interesting thought that that this
whole thing start right around a tree
yeah yeah it's got of an Angel and you
know that looks like a there's kind of a
lot of very interesting deeply connected
things to our past as Humanity yes and
the tree well as it pertains this is a
interesting connection and one that
people have to understand a tree only
comes up inth ology even it is known
that he Nimrod was a sun god right so
when he died especially the time of year
when the winter came they it was said
that he went into the
trees so when you were kind of mourning
or grieving his his leaving in
remembrance of him you would cut down a
tree to keep your God with you in your
house everen of course so that is truly
what they would do interesting and
that's why um in Jeremiah he speaks
specifically about not having a
Christmas tree not cutting down a tree
and bringing house fing it to your floor
and all that I've read that it's uh it's
basically Sun worship like in the winter
time the sun is not out as much and you
know for imagine it's like your first
winter you're like is this ever going to
change you know we we know it's we've
been we've lived this thing out for
years so we're like oh yeah Summer's
going to come back yeah but there was a
time when they would
uh look at that evergreen tree as a
memorial like everything's dead except
this this is a memorial that the sun
will return it's like a sun worship type
thing and it would almost hold the
semblance of the power of that God
within it so it was like you're holding
on to a spark of that God until they
return into their original form in the
sky basically as we make that connection
then we go straight into certain
monuments that are actually the same
thing in
India um they will have the lingum and
it also is depicted just as a mound
that's rounded the phallic symbol we
have the Egyptian one of course that
we're seeing on the right which is an
obelisk so every time an obelisk whether
it has inscriptions are not on it is uh
scen it is actually the symbol for that
it's interesting how much is related
back to Canan as well and um Walter VI
mentions this in some of his total
onslaughts series mhm Freemasons in a
lot of the occult World want to be known
as sons of Cain they like to be in their
book somewhere it is actually cited that
they are sons of Cain today as we know
it again there was a mapole involved
here but that is also when you get the
the ribbons that everyone's dancing
around and all this stuff it's a
fertility ritual that you are performing
you might dress up you might make it
look beautiful and most of the time even
though this picture is not depicting it
you would have um the inner circle
around the pole would be men and the
Outer Circle would be women and they'd
be going opposite directions with their
their ribbons becoming intertwined with
one another and that was kind of like
your next sex sexual partner in the
order of things and then you just keep
going and going you mean like uh whoever
like when you're at the end of your rope
whoever you're next to or something like
it's just like a sexual rouette or
something yes exactly so originally of
course they got closed on in the picture
but it would not have been it would have
been just an orgy that you're having and
I included the heliopoulos
because that was in Egypt or Babylon
they all these cultures had a temple
where all of these gods to the sun were
kept in a some kind of Helio you'll find
that a helio Opus a helio Temple
something always to the Sun and these
kinds of symbols would be seen again not
just in the form of as we think of a
tree or a maple but again the Obelisk
well yeah the top of that pole is
eclipsing the Sun and they're all
revolving around it I'm sure it's like
heliocentric they're all revolving
around the Sun that's the sun worship
ceremony okay so here's where
Jesus God wants you to know like he puts
it in there he wants you to go looking
for this and IT addresses it in Isaiah
57:5 you who burn with lust Among The
Oaks under every Green Tree who
Slaughter your children in The Valleys
under the cffs of the
Rocks so I like that version although I
do like to stick with the KJV it says
burn with less cuz that is depicting it
so well yeah and it wasn't just a
sycamore tree as cybel or um smiris it
becomes the oak trees it becomes the
pine trees the Evergreen any kind of
tree in some way is actually used in
different cultures to depict the same
God and rituals of sexual stuff so in
the KJV just to highlight it says
inflaming yourselves with Idols under
every Green
Tree um kind of of course depicting more
of the biological response which would
be there so then in Jeremiah as we were
speaking of the Christmas tree he says
long ago you broke off your yoke and
tore off your bonds you said I will not
serve you indeed on every Hill and under
every spreading tree you lay down as a
prostitute oh wow that's some harsh
language me under the tree in
Ezekiel it's amazing I encourage people
to read the entire chapter of Ezekiel 8
it speaks directly to all of what was
going on even in the times before Jesus
came on the scene of how
unfortunately the Jew Jewish culture and
religion was already corrupt it was not
worshiping a true God it had all the
statues in the temple if you read in the
first couple verses and then we get to
this point which is relevant what we're
speaking of chapter 8 verse 17 and 18
then he said unto me hast thou seen this
oh son of man is it a light thing to the
house of Judah that they commit the
Abominations which they commit here for
they have filled the land with v Ence
and have returned to provoke me to anger
and lo they put the branch to their nose
therefore will I also deal in Fury mine
ey shall not spare neither will I have
pity and though they cry in my ears mine
ears with a loud voice yet will I not
hear them so we think this sounds kind
of
silly putting the branch to your nose
but if you look at altars that wiccans
have or the cultist or Satanist they'll
usually have a fragment of a branch on
the altar in some form or a wreath or
something they've weaved together from a
tree to actually symbolize the same
thing the same God the same abundance
from the earth if you
will and
so it's just sad to me because it's
almost 500 years before Jesus comes on
the
scene and that's why I like to just
really um differentiate actually between
Judaism and being Hebrew because I
believe Jesus he didn't go to the their
schools he was schooled by his mother
and by the Holy Spirit to know what he
knows and he if you will didn't practice
Judaism he was a Hebrew burn born into
that culture but he was one of the true
people of God who stayed pure the
Israelites and the Hebrews are different
than Jews in my
book anyway just a side note to that but
in Ezekiel this is a commentary on this
verse and it actually says the branch
mentioned is probably an Ashira a tree
or a wooden pole that stood for the
fertility goddess it was essentially a
phallic symbol God says that their
wickedness was the same as sticking that
Idol right in his nose right in his face
we we need to be mindful if we're
falling into this category of doing
Abominations and also in a sense
returning to God so we're showing up the
church and we're doing what we think is
good but we're practicing certain things
in our personal lives
and even things that we don't consider
sin if it's connected to the occult it's
sin it's an Abomination so if there's
something you're praying about and it
seems that God isn't responding maybe an
analysis needs to be done are you living
a double life yeah and how many I was
just saying most Christian would remove
a Buddha statue from their home or
something but yet still have the
Christmas tree or the superhero figurine
that repres literally repres reprs Thor
or Hades or Mercury or Zeus or whatever
I think this is why we're losing the
young people is the hypocrisy they're
actually seeing yeah it doesn't match up
they got the people who look perfect and
are Towing the line but then they're
seeing that they don't and they're
wondering where is the real line to toe
where does it lie between being
completely extreme on one end or extreme
on the other but yet not just like
walking the middle ground in being gray
in all areas like you have to know the
truth you have to and how are we
supposed to support each other as um
brothers and sisters of Christ if we're
not aware of these things right like we
would just fall into if you will just
kind of like a a latrine hole it just
kind of like oh we're going to be War
yeah so The Druids again proof that it
kind of morphed into different types of
trees they're
actually as it states here Druids the
Learned class among the ancient Kelts
whose name means knowing or finding the
oak tree so it does turn into other
trees and different sacrifices um of
those things of of basically humans
underneath that
tree so just a little that's what the
word Druid means is finding the oak tree
knowing or finding the oak tree
so this is a n since we mentioned the
gods that are associated with kind of
being bisexual transgender and so on I
wanted to give examples Samaran or
Canaanite on the right um I don't know
why in both the Egyptian and the
Canaanite cultures they depicted as a
naked female sprawling throughout the
sky as though the you know the sun moon
and stars were in her belly and other
areas and life earth right and life all
came from her kind of thing but they
did and um interestingly enough she was
also depicted as a cow sometimes whose
great body formed the sky and Heavens a
sycamore tree or a giant sa suckling
many piglets and that kind of you know
if you suckle many piglets that's where
she gets kind of the idea of many
breasts um and Collie having many
breasts and being blue that kind of
thing um however like the sky right um a
pot on her head seemed to be many
cultures spoke on that but it was her as
though it's viewing females as though
that's really the only function they
have is to birth children um you know
which is not at all God's plan for that
you're not just a tool or a something to
be used but that's where they got this
idea um abortion of course we know that
with bale Kash molak Marduk as we saw
all those chambers for burning babies
and and
humans um was part of of worship I mean
it just makes so much sense in our
culture today how we have this um you
know anti-abortion bills and you're not
allowed to do that and what church steps
up and starts offering this uh in fact
we'll pay for it Church of sat Church of
Satan and it's like we're still like
literally sending babies to Marduk yeah
well they go through a lot of um lengths
actually unfortunately to actually breed
more children usually and through the
ories through orgies through a lot of
the Satanic ritual abuse that happens
there's always lots of babies born from
that that are conceived and that's on
purpose not only through um invoking
demons and actually reaching a different
Transcendence or illuminated state but
also to create more babies more flesh to
be sacrificed as blood I watched a
documentary which I it was a well done
yeah and he speaks on it very
well um Out of the Shadows or out of
Shadows Sorry by Mike Smith exposes this
so don't take my word for it go look at
it we're also seeing that in sound of
freedom and so on um but in pedophilia
you're actually it's part of bail
worship Marduk MCH
Kash um the Rothchilds and world's Elite
that control banking are involved in
that we should all probably know this by
now that the government does take part
in and all of
this in yoga a lot of our video just got
taken down I know it stopped um in yoga
a lot of positions that you're
practicing are for sexual UMC stuff and
it does usually involve
pedophilia U we'll be seeing that later
where this I have proof for that in the
next couple of slides however child sex
trafficking is linked with this
otherwise if you don't have a market for
this right you don't have a perpet
ual demand
or what is it surplus of it for blood
sacrifice and children to be offered up
constantly it says that lots of blood is
needed to open the supposed portal of
CERN or AKA arch of Bale erected all
over the world for molok and Marduk to
take form and bring him into this
Dimension to take rulership this is if
you will they're waiting for their God
to show up CERN is very CERN is very
interesting I mean I think we should do
a whole piece getting to the bottom of
CERN that would be fascinating but but
um I haven't I haven't heard them um
like offering babies for it yet I have
the picture of the Ark of Bale in
today's world we hear of it always
spoken of as Pala they cover up like the
city of Babylon or Bal as palm a lot of
times so that's just something to look
for in the Hindu worship we have Sun
Temple at conar it's been written up
because it has depictions of group sex
gay sex all
positions polygamy Pander prostitution
orgies oral anal adultery and even
beastiality within it was heterosexual
sex like not
allowed basically if you that's a good
point say something because it's true
you're not supposed to be heterosexual
or you were Against The Gods or spirits
entering you interesting you are not
going to have these CL
the shaman
type Powers if you you could be
polygamist or prostitute yes as long as
there's multiple partners involved
that's the thing it's everything but
what God wants right God wants one man
one woman in a marriage that says no
prostitution polygamy their motto should
be uh do as thou Wilt is the whole of
the law except for if you do what God
God wants you to do then you can't do
that yes that's our only law I even see
it in the Christian World though that's
the sad part I see people saying like if
you obey God you're putting yourself
back under the law and you're basically
not saved like because you don't believe
in God's grace if you if you do what God
asks those wheels that you see on the
building are exactly what we've been
talking about they are sun wheels for
the seasons but in each spokes I have I
have a close-up of this you have each
yoga pose for each phase of the sun wow
yes on each side of the building there's
that proof just from that temple on the
left here we have how you do the yoga
poses but it's from a different Temple
and that why that matters is because in
one form or fashion every one of their
temples is about these positions then we
get into Yoni or yonic fertility Cults
for the female
genitalia these gods that are worshiped
under that is Diana Ishtar ashth aard
and Ashira so the same as Bale worship
it's just using Ashira again it's a
place to have these sexual ories it's to
gather on a hillside usually in the
Groves in the trees and start having
this um this is actually what Easter
Sunday is so when the sun would come up
on a Hillside and those Rays would hit
you everyone would be standing around if
you will probably
naked around a pole of some sort getting
ready to
in participate in those kinds of things
probably doing some yoga stretches
waiting for the sun to rise yep
yep so this is where it's it gets hard
for a lot of people because even when
we've dressed it up and you're like yeah
I'm reading this section right here
Transcendence achieved through deeper
penetration and stretching female organs
out yeah that's pain so when someone is
in like severe state of pain you're not
thinking straight like you're kind of in
a days and so that's
Transcendence like whatever chemical is
being released which is like a survival
type of thing your body's trying
to tell you not to do that right do that
or like cope is being achieved once
again this is just an attack on the way
that God set this beautiful thing up
because you know he designed it to be a
pleasurable experience and and to use
somebody who's giving you pleasure it's
like this others focused opposite thing
and now it's like the devil's perverted
that to the point where it's like I'm
going to get pleasure off of you getting
pain MH and and I'm getting enjoyment
off of that even though I know it hurts
you and it's like if you hurt your
private parts hard enough you're bet
you're going to go into some higher
state of of mind you know what I mean
like I can't even imagine like this is
awful that this is even flipped into
this you know this is what this is what
is enjoyable but I see how this is a
portal because what it's doing it's
getting you out of your mind taking away
your capabilities a choice cannot be
made and and if the goal is to be
inhibited right is that the word
inhibited inhibited um you're now a host
to whatever Spirit has entered inside of
you what I it's amazing that you brought
that up but what I was getting at is a
lot of people say oh I'm gonna go get a
new Easter dress I'm gonna go look cute
for this so almost as though we
forgotten where we've come from here
what it was all about we are now even as
females or males we might get a new suit
or something right we're dressing up for
this almost as though it's a thing of
reverence something to be amazing right
and then we're forgetting that where
this comes from is actually going
towards sexual things you're getting a
new outfit to look to get your new
partner I highlight this because Shiva
in in Hinduism and the Kundalini or the
serpent spirit it's always the phallic
or phus and Yogi worship um why because
I don't know why they seem so deep and
entrenched in it but they actually have
statues of this as well that they'll
pour milk onto the phallic
symbol
interesting um to basically
almost fondle the God if you will for
what you want W and and the the um what
do you call the chakras or whatever like
this right doesn't it start in the lower
regions it's the pelvic region right but
the ultimate goal is for it to be on
your third eye which is your shakana
glory this is where the god resides and
so it's like it begins with all this de
activity and allows that demonic um
snake space Spirit snake that's what
they call it they call a snake into your
mind that's what the end goal is I don't
get it I don't get it people are mad at
God because he's demanding worship and
what does it mean to worship God it's to
obey him what are we obeying the Ten
Commandments do good to others and and
love God
yeah and that's so terrible in
comparison to Satan who demands pain
yeah right pain torture like cut your
do these Terrible Things by the way we
take over your mind you can't control
yourself anymore like think about what
half these rappers went through from P
Diddy and stuff you know to get what
they got God has asking too much I I
remember the first time that I ever
heard that many of these rappers have
had to engage in homosexual activities
in order to get famous as a rapper yeah
that totally changed the concept for rap
like I I actually liked rap I listened
to it but then I could no longer see
these rappers was like what did you do
to get there what did you do to get
there what did you or be gaset to the
point that their mind breaks and then
they just have psychotic breaks in front
of the public and we're just here
laughing at them or what have you yeah
man but I put this in there just for
proof but Indian culture has an entire
book on all of this and how to do it
it's called The Kamas Sutra that's all
I'm going to say pornography of course
I'm I'm just going to say it comes from
all of this like all of it requires that
you see a naked body doing things and
you lust after it you actually start you
know wanting to participate in that and
have that manifest you know what that's
a good point going back to your previous
slide someone could say oh I'm not
engaging in that I'm not doing orgies
and all of that but if you're viewing it
and then self Haring you're yeah you're
a part of it yeah yeah yeah
so and it's unnatural again you're not
supposed to be the one pleasuring
yourself so in rape as well these are
all the gods Isis Islam Hinduism Zeus
Marduk satanic sexual rituals and
practices as it goes along with this
it's not your choice it is actually an
act of the gods or a Transcendence which
you're not supposed to really care about
your own well-being in but the other
person or whatever did this spill out
into society cuz you're saying rape rape
is when uh sex is forced if if it's in a
context of of a religious ceremony it
could be assumed that everyone is
consensual doing this so when I say that
go out into society was part of their
rituals to go out and grab people who
weren't part of the ceremony and
actually perform these acts yes they
abduct people a lot of the time and so
it's not consensual a lot of the time
even certain children who are raised in
this they are not consensual they are
forced to do all of it and also you know
it's worthy of saying that the the human
mind does not develop until 24 so you're
if you're engaging in this in your
teenage years you're not thinking with
all the Pistons firing anyway so yeah
war and killings we I was shocked about
this but it's also just the blood bath
that is supposed to ensue to bring the
underworld realm to Earth here to bring
Satan if you will into our Dimension
just as much blood as you
can take is important so I always I
always think like when you see this
really Uber satanic stuff there's always
some spiritual truth that it's
counterfeiting right and salvation is
through the blood of Jesus and you know
it's like we've been washed in his blood
I mean there's a lot of blood imagery in
the Bible and the devil just flipped
that narrative and and made it this like
physical thing rather than the blood of
Jesus one person that spilled it for
everybody right he's like no we're going
to spill everybody's blood so that you
can you know achieve whatever you want
I'm not saying all of them but they want
to almost make you mental yes
Psychopaths psycho um sociopaths and
narcissists that's their goal so that
you lose from what I understand you lose
attachment with the Holy Spirit or your
conscience you just don't have one
anymore yeah it this is a relational
based life that we live in right your
relationship to God and your
relationship to man I mean that's what
the Ten Commandments is about right you
wouldn't lie or cheat or steal or kill
um you know people if you truly loved
them and so this is like disassociating
you from those things it's it's it's in
a weird way it's just attacking that Ten
Commandments which is supposed to be how
we're operating life out of yeah and
it's just perverting that whole system
yeah it's just so sad then we get to the
idea of population control by the high
up
Elites um again to kill others deemed
unnecessary you have this in Helen
paty's books you have this that is kind
of where you get the ideas of the higher
EP Ault the cabalist you start
understanding that their ideas and
Alistar Crowley if you will and Anton L
they all have this understanding um
that people need to be off because
they're not important in this plan of
the elites taking over and having their
goal be accomplished in the world so
they use many ways of doing that toxins
air pollute pollution so drinking
actually I know people are like no
drinking is like benign it's you know
moderation it's great
so that is actually the Pagan view it's
the light versus the dark and having a
balance of it within you that this whole
moderation and tolerance thing seems to
come from just try it once even the
mindset of trying it once and you're
fine it's not a spiritual thing or a
violation of God's will for your life
that's where it comes from but the gods
these demons have actually um masquerad
as is dianis Shiva Odin Voodoo and who
do is actually they use drinking a lot
but it's you know they'll drink it even
as a shot to like honor the gods or
their
ancestors they'll use it to invoke
Spirits again that's a way to Lose
Yourself your frontal lobe from working
so that you give in to whatever is
flowing through you at that moment I
thought it was really interesting right
there luciferian brewing and malting
handycraft beers oh is a thing there's
so many like satanic things on beer
bottles yeah you just go down the beer
aisle at uh Walmart or something and
you'll see like Wicked beer and it's got
like a an apple hang like this apple
hanging off of a dead tree and stuff and
it's like why is it called wicked why is
there an Apple yeah the hexagram of
course is used to in invoke demons all
the time in everything pointed star yes
they claim though that there's an
overlap with the shape of the top of
Saturn from NASA's photos that looks
like an eye of a storm also I'll show
that in just a minute and some of them
claim that it's allseeing eye on Saturn
and that if you will I read this thing
they believe that Satan and his demons
which they want to get more acquainted
with almost live in Saturn there's a
black Cube like inside of Saturn I don't
know how they know this stuff I don't I
have a picture of that next but that's
not biblical no it's not and then you
have the all seeing I show up with the
hexagram and all this stuff also in
Hinduism yoga spirit ISM everything like
it just shows up everywhere mhm so but
it's interesting that this symbol which
we are going to talk about that people
think is the Star of David given to the
Jews it was actually made by a friend of
Hitler's named Rothchild yeah even
though is a star of ran and that is
important because a star of ran is
mentioned twice in the
Bible let's take a look at it so this is
a star of ran looks like the sun huh the
first one one was in Roman and
Babylonian worship of Ishtar of course
and Saturn and that is where we bring in
those verses Amos 5 26-27 and acts 7:
43 it talks about how the people have
given themselves to their God and the
God's symbol of their allegiance is the
star of ran here is the actual picture
that their claiming is Saturn the cube
and this whole idea of the cube
unraveling to become the cross they you
know I could see that a little bit the
Israelites fell into this deeply
unfortunately anal and oral sex yes so
they actually have a place in the Bible
in the next slide called Bale peor it's
mentioned by name the valley or Mount of
peor where they actually did this they
gave into seeing the women doing this
and participated so this is the verse
numbers 25:
1-9 and Israel Abode in
sham which is weird because no pun
intended and the people began to commit
where the word came from right to commit
whoredom with the daughters of Moab and
they called the people unto the
sacrifices of their gods and the people
did eat and bowed down to their gods and
Israel joined herself unto B peor and
the anger of the Lord was kindled
against Israel and the Lord said unto
Moses take all the heads of the people
and hang them up before the Lord against
the son that the fierce anger of the
Lord may be turned away from Israel and
Moses said unto the judges of Israel
slay ye everyone his men that were
joined unto B peor and behold one of the
children of Israel came up and brought
unto his Brethren a Midian iish woman in
the sight of Moses and in the sight of
all the congregation of the children of
Israel who were weeping before the door
of the Tabernacle of the congregation
and when Phineas the son of Eleazar the
son of Aaron the priest saw it he rose
up from among the congregation and took
a javelin in his hand and he went after
the man of Israel into the tent and
thrust both of them through the man of
Israel and the woman through her belly
so the plague was stayed from the
children of Israel and those that died
in the plague were 20 and 4,000 so
they're not telling you is they engaged
in this and there was enough of them
that got sick from it so the name baale
again means Lord or owner and peor put
together is to open wide or openings or
orifices of the body so when you put the
two together in this place that they
called it you can actually go there
today they actually have Bale peor the
valley or this Mount we're going to see
picture of that too but it means lord of
the openings really wow um yeah or God
of the holes so this is it today where
they have symbols of uh the phallic
symbols I'll just share this because I
did not expect to find this in the
talmood um it says in the story that
Sanhedrin one of the men in Sanhedrin
tells of sabta a Jew who attempted to
show his contempt for B peor he
defecated in the temple and cleaned
himself on the Statue only to be
commended for his efforts he then
entered uncovered himself before it and
wiped himself on the Idol's nose whilst
the aites praised him saying no man has
ever served this Idol in this way Rashi
a French Rabbi of the late 11th century
said bpor that they would uncover before
it the end of the rectum and bring forth
excrement this is its Worship in light
of this we should be grateful that it
was the Israelites God who won this
particular battle and who went on to
create the dominant religions of the
modern world so he was not in favor of
it thank goodness but you actually would
offer up your excrement as a sacrifice
to the God and then the sexual act would
occur as well wow the tud I thought that
was a Jewish book but it says tmu what
is that well I'm glad you asked there's
the Babylonian and
Jewish talmood but they are both books
that the Jewish people read and it's
their holy book these are their
traditions of their fathers that they
read as their holy books so these are
like the Zionist and stuff like these
people call themselves Jews but are not
Revelation talks about and stuff and
they take like control the world and
they represent that hexagram okay you
know
they they uh fly that flag then there's
profanity and cussing which a lot of us
even as Christians right we're like oh
it's fine fine so first of all there's a
goddess of that persone she was known
for her cursing like heavy cursings but
it was always to bring hatred and
torture onto her people that she hated
like just and that's what people started
doing that's why you curse right you
usually because you're angry at
something and you want to get back at it
so you do that to other people you
pronounce curses on them and before that
happened
um I'm going to attach this way back and
I know I'm making connecting the dots
but you would do this as you cast spells
on people because in the wiccan world in
the occultt world you are again you're
you're claiming your gods have the power
to get back at this person please do it
on my behalf like just let's invoke that
curse on them so they still do it all
the time and they'll just use different
gods like you know as they do in movies
which ones again it's just a counterfeit
for you know words are powerful you can
say positive words you can say you know
blessing words you can say you know just
things that that help bolster people up
and and you can also tear them down so
this is the devil just once again
tweaking with that okay so meditation we
know this it's the core of Hinduism bud
Buddhism judaic cabalism Islam and from
their Roots they're leaking into
Christianity we see it churches are
having yoga in their churches they're
having seances even and we have the
verses we know what we're getting into
is sorcery divination adultery
fornication all these things like the
verse says people who will not be going
to heaven So Raving clubbing and
partying we kind of again we we think
we're the only ones dealing with this
but they had that back then satalia
pagan feast in honor of Saturn was a
week-long feast held from December 17th
through the
23rd kids were off school everyone was
off school slaves and slave owners would
actually consider themselves almost all
equal at that point in time to engage in
these Rights sexual rights where no age
was excluded um no gender wow and no
social class and they only were allowed
to wear their
underwear so yeah Pride
marches W yeah but they did have
gambling they had the sacrifices going
on of human beings and drinking blood
but the children were given
dolls it's really weird dolls that
represented the human sacrifice to like
cradle and yet be numbed again like oh
this is the next baby we're going to be
sacrificing kind of thing so they had
pudding I I read this they had blood
pudding that was given to all toci pants
as well um to partake of that sacrifice
I'm thinking of those uh spirit cooking
pictures and videos right now of all the
celebrities like eating the cake that
looks like a human and stuff yeah so as
you can imagine why this is on this page
is because it was it was just an entire
big in the most mellow way I'm going to
use the word term party or the term
party it's just orgies rapes and
pedophilia Galore but this is what we
ALS tie with Christmas this is the
Romans way of what became Christmas
there was
saturnalia yeah so this would be what it
might have looked like and this was the
most kosher I found where you can't tell
everyone's pretty well uncovered but if
you look hard enough there's always
children in there and I might add that
sometimes that's where I think we get
the idea of the cherubim being tiny
little angels and cute little naked
children because they almost depict them
as that in these festivals wasn't Cupid
one of the names of the Gods and how is
that depicted exactly yeah he was so
then we get to TVs and video games and
screens in
general Saturn's Black Cube was also
known as the swastika or the hexagram it
equals
666 if you count up its sides they all
say that about the cross two triangles
over another is a Seal of
Solomon interesting which he used to
call upon demons as we know the hexagram
is to invoke demons yeah in Masonic
symbols it is there as a black cube in
the papacy symbols a skull and
crossbones uses the Saturn's Black Cube
as something as well the allseeing ey
but Saturn was the god of death time and
judgment or laws and times his name was
also Bale Kronos and
ran as mystical stories of Saturn goes
he was known for eating his children who
Saturn oh Kronos Bale and
ran so this is also where we get Santa
Claus oh Krampus
Krampus Kronos Santa Claus all the
little kids running from Krampus in
folklore as he went to go do this his
wife offered him a black stone to eat
instead and he took it as a replacement
so that's where you start almost
offering gifts in order to not be eaten
if you will that's a part of this um
similar to Halloween as you offer up
certain the pumpkin outside to scare
away the demon or actually have them eat
it instead as a form of food um so you
can be spared it's also attached to so
TVs and everything are attached to
Pandora's Box and that
story somehow is linked to the veil
being ripped in the temple that they say
was actually a cube or the cross as well
that you could actually fold into a cube
nicely and
um when you get to this opening the veil
or the mysteries of the Gods in
Pandora's Box leads to all kinds of
Abominations of the earth well what is
the quickest way you can view all the
Abominations of the Earth today the
screen yes and this is TV
www uh when you look at the I don't know
if it's like the it's like a Hebrew
thing but every Hebrew character has a
number attached to it and V and W are
both six that's why they say that the
it's the v v v or whatever it's uh like
the monster logo is is three of these
vaves and it's a 666 but www is 666 yeah
that's the worldwide web you get tangled
up in the web yeah I I you you have to
like you know kind of chuckle at the
cleverness that it is called what it is
and and we're so we're so accustomed to
these terms and these things in our
daily liveses that we don't recognize it
for what it is it really truly is a web
and you know it's got a lot of people
caught in this thing the knowledge of
Good and Evil you can use it for good
but there's I mean you can be trying to
look at good and Evil's going to pop up
in your face right so it's also known as
the cabba or the cabala isn't that
interesting like the Muslims go and do
their pilgrimage around the stone of
Mecca which is known as the cabba or
Allah
cabala okay so you just if you change it
and just spell it a little differently
it's all the same cousins though exactly
combining the words and you can spell
Cube differently too cube with a k or a
c and it's the same thing but and I'm
just putting this on there because I'm
just reporting it but they say that it
was the Israelites that rejected God
God's word and when they went with the
people who are basically going to follow
ishmail as the chosen promised son of
Abraham
then you get the stone of Mecca and all
these teachings that are so strange
like it kind of goes with that and proof
of that that they had on here is the
stone which the builders refused has
become this The Headstone of the
corner so a black stone ironically the
black a black meteor was also the sign
of cybel so
lastly it is said that the black stone
fell from the sky originally one of the
precious stones of Heaven remember that
Satan was a covering had coverings of
all precious stones but that God
deprived it of its Brilliance they say
which would have illuminated the world
from one end to the other aka the Holy
Grail coined by the
Nazis the Nazi Explorer Otto Ron who
called The Stone Lucifer's Grail
originally folklore is that you see the
stone and you get eternal life so you
can see the occults kind of um
gnosticism coming out there that if you
view you enough Abominations of the
earth you will find yourself in it and
eternal life through it I just I just
think it's really fascinating that that
it's like people are seeking the same
thing everybody wants eternal life
everybody wants the Fountain of Youth
you can have that it's a free gift that
free gift is given from Jesus's price
that he paid for our Salvation yeah but
yet they want to find it in all this
junk yeah it's right there it's like a
gift you got to go do all these
debaucherous awful things to try and
Achieve that which they're promising
that if you do those things you get that
but it's right here yeah it's offered
free yeah so I had to include this
particular last part that last paragraph
because this is what they say a box of
viewing and learning all Abominations
containing all the evil of mankind a box
of the unnatural and confinement
ironically following all these teachings
and everything becomes a cube you are
shut up in lost and confused a prison
cell to separate man from God while
trying to fit everything inside the box
we have become imprisoned this symbol is
a symbol of human oppression you think
of the good that that has really come
from the TV I think there's some good
things I mean there's Ministry videos
and we obviously make videos and you
know there's there's positive uses to
the media but you think of the
overwhelming negative things that that
box has done to the world yeah it's the
motivation behind it yeah and even if
it's not negative the amount of time
someone uses to engage in it yeah is an
issue so again one would ask why did we
just go through all this disgusting
things that we did I know we need to be
able to see it need a shower yeah
because we need to be able to see it and
not participate in it again it's like we
need a reminder what does it look like
how do we stay clean and pure of this
how do we use it in a good way instead
of a bad way well some of them of course
don't use it all but like media you can
use it for good and view good
things but I would suggest that we all
need to take a look around us hopefully
this was the groundwork this was the
foundation which has given you the eyes
to see the ears to hear and start
realizing it all around you even in our
churches in our schools our families
everything that's what we need to do
like clean house yep and that's where we
stand with God then each one of us
should come away hopefully understanding
like I did I looked at all this and we
were not just given one chance we were
given a second chance at life so you
have the flood first that was our second
well second chance then you've got all
of this going on God's trying to get to
you every way that he can but Satan's
trying to get to you even harder like
inundate you we have a choice and I have
to say that we all have fallen into Bill
Worship in some way
and so that struck me like we
deserve much less than the symbol the
grace and love and the sacrifice that
God gave for us but he is so
merciful it's incredible we see that
through Israel's history when they fell
into paganism and they cried out to the
Lord and he forgave them and restored
them
completely and so it just boils down to
our choice yeah yeah but God is there
you're right with his grace restoring
power yes and I think a third
opportunity came when Jesus died on the
cross of course and now the gift is open
for anyone to receive him someone who's
who's caught in the web and so deeply
entrenched into all these
atrocities God still sees and he hears
MH and uh and is willing to save and he
forgives yeah and we need him like we
can't even if we were to try to stay
away from all of these entrapments that
are coming at us we have a nature that
wants to dve to them go towards them we
need him as our savior it should still
be said though in reference to the text
you read earlier that there is a line
there is a point when God's grace will
expire yes indeed you know and and he is
a gentleman he will not keep pushing and
pushing there's no Force at all yeah and
so hearing this
information understanding this
information a choice needs to be made
we're held accountable and if someone
decides to say no God has to respect
that choice you know and there is a
point where he stops hearing and seeing
for sure and I just want to encourage
people there's amazing stories of people
who have been through all the addictions
in the world all this junk Satanic
ritual abuse even there are resources
out there I want to give you them
because there are places that will
actually train you to actually detect
when someone might be a child in slavery
someone who's in sexual slavery or just
slavery in general around the world
their name is operation Underground
Railroad M yeah not only do they train
you to see this whe whether you want to
take an entire organization maybe your
whole company wants to go for training
in this but individuals can go for this
but they have missions where they
actually go Free People beautiful um
there's another one which you can get
involved in international Justice
Mission let me make sure I made that
yeah so that is the right one they are
two amazing places that I haven't worked
with but I've seen people work with that
are doing a great job so you can support
people in that and there's counseling as
well which I will give links for I will
provide links for if you've been through
unspeakable things God has a plan for
you he can help you beautiful so that's
what we have for you today I I hope that
you see the benefit in going through all
of this um I'll go ahead and have Mikey
close us out with all of the
advertisements well if you want to
support this ministry you can do so
simply and freely by by clicking that
thumbs up it really helps get this video
out into the algorithm you know it's a
it's a big machine that's out there and
there's a lot of bad stuff getting the
the platform but if you want to help
this ministry get out there click the
thumbs up uh if this is your first time
click subscribe click the notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any future
episodes if you want to support this
ministry you can do so financially by
going to Little Light studios. TV and
there's a link there for donation or you
can buy some interesting and cool shirts
that are nice ice breakers to open up to
people about spiritual things and we
sell those at lightwear do shop and you
can really wear your witness which also
helps us out and if you think that
there's not a lot of good media out
there then check out little like kids we
now have a children's ministry that
we're building up and so help us out go
over there subscribe get those numbers
up your help means the world to us and
we want to keep producing uh content
that's going to be beneficial to
children and and introduce them to
Christ and we just we know we cannot do
this ministry without you it's all
because of you guys so thank you so much
for your support and we'll see you next
time if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little like kids do you have questions
about the Bible that you've been
struggling to find the answers for video
Bible study or VBS for short is a
YouTube channel that answers your Bible
questions in 5 minutes or less check out
these easy to understand comprehensive
videos talking about everything from
what happens when you die to why does
God allow suffering make it your goal to
deepen your relationship with Christ
this year and subscribe to video bible
study on YouTube to help you along your
journey it's proven that people remember
things that they see more than what they
hear lightwear believes the best way to
share your witness is to wear your
witness lightwear has all kinds of
graphic te's that are great attention
grabbing way to share the gospel so head
on over to lightwear do shop and check
out all the cool graphic te's what do
you want people to remember when they
see
[Music]
you